il a des enfants la fin sondage ya pas
mal de gens aussi
voilà qui nous regardent qui était à 53
% d'accord avec le fait quoi là qu'ils
pouvaient avoir peut-être avoir d'autres
circonstances à à ce qu un navire est ce
que tu comprends que des gens qui
puissent être choqués et toi quelle est
ta théorie tu sur le virus en fait les
séries ils sont parés d'autres marées
sinon ça sert à rien ils mangeraient au
[Rires]
parc logiciel qu'elle devient porte pas
le manquer vous êtes un homme qui l'aï
nommé l'a tenu pendant la montée
lalalalala affirmé de la coopération
chinoise
c'est exceptionnel franchement ça a été
exceptionnel d'arguin a été folle et
afida procès qu'il aime bien figurez
vous l'appelez elle répond c'est moi
c'est l'un de mes plus grands fous rires
depuis très très rarement
kelly c'est quoi votre meilleur moment
alors c'était un débat sur la chanteuse
angel et comme d'habitude ce bail à
notre ami mathieu qui est un petit peu
pété les plombs ça lui arrive souvent et
moi j'ai bien aimé ça m'a bien fait rire
c'est parti
[Musique]
mais elle a fait un tube
[Applaudissements]
18 ans mais il va faire le guignol en
boîte de nuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas mon geste je comprends qu'elles
soient fatigués parce que si on a 18 ans
tout ce qui est tombée sur la gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai créé ma voiture je le retire du
monde médiatique
[Applaudissements]
c'était excitant
oui beaucoup d'une banque audi pense que
j'ai fait 80 chevaux pour le coup en
province mais c'est vrai bravo géraldine
pigault votre moment alors on sait vous
avez la france à vos pieds non mais ce
qui m'a plu c'est que vous avez aussi
maintenant pousser les frontières et
vous avez les stars internationales qui
serait absolument le tennis bat cinéma
tout le monde vient et veut absolument
en découdre et rencontrer cyril hanouna
tués lors mal non c'est qu'il a qui sait
quoi je vais pas vous allez voir même
[Musique]
bien sûr syrien al oula à il regretté
les autres
[Musique]
tu vas t'entraîner ivey a fait tousser
ou de rock dans d'autres de rock mon ami
je mange je mouille le mec c'est has
been a imprimé une femme nagui mais
franchement merci pour les tenues
franchement vous êtes magnifique et de
chaussée et votre anglais votre anglais
vrai dire j'ai eu novak djokovic ont dm
encore la semaine dernière et roland
garros vous le savez ça va être de fin
septembre
quand il allait faire j'espère j'espère
qu'il fera peut-être les boîtes avec moi
oui voilà j'espère voilà parce que c'est
quand même le numéro un mondial c'est
peut-être peut-être devenir même le plus
grand joueur de tous les temps il est qu
à trois grand chelems voilà de rodger
federer etc voilà j'espère que novak
fera les boîtes avec moi et sachez qu'on
est en train d'organiser le match entre
wawrinka benoît p ah oui et gaël monfils
témoin à dulles
on va l'organiser sachez le et on va
essayer de le retransmettre sur ces 8 le
match le paddle ce sera je pense pendant
roland-garros où il s'est même essayé de
le faire et on s'entraînera d'ailleurs
un peu cet été avec elle pour essayer dé
battre gaël que j'ai eues la semaine
d'année aussi qui m'a dit sûr et certain
on va les plier est sûr et certain qu'on
va les fracasser alors jean michel
mercier quoi votre moment c'était un
prime juste avant noël c'est le ba-ba
noël je crois et mathieu on lui a fait
la surprise de lui faire rencontrer un
fan
[Musique]
non
enfin les fans
enfin l'iphone n'était pas sérieuse dans
mon coeur je peux apporter la photo bien
sûr même apporter une photo mais pas de
votre vie si vous voulez un million chez
nous elle me bat si c'est vrai oui tous
les
[Applaudissements]
matthew
à
idem quand même battu rejeter mais
mathieu tu es fier de toi match
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il reste très très très in toujours très
digne très très classe ici pour ça qu'on
aime matthieu delormeau bravo mathieu
battu vous savez que je vous aime fort
hills est exceptionnel et franchement
même ça il faut le faire et pourquoi
mathieu il est tellement exceptionnel
dans ces moments là et si c'était génial
sophie c'est quoi votre moment c'était
pendant le confinement c'était les
émissions en zoom ce soir j'aimerais
beaucoup que vous aviez invité tous vos
potes away sur zoom et tout le monde
était en pleine forme tout le monde fait
charrier c'était hyper drôle et
d'ailleurs je crois que vous aviez une
idée de la grande feria qui graal en
plus une des marques comme l'arbre
wallon tournant avec la grosse rigolade
et là gros chars y avait exactement de
ce fait qui sera un dérivé je vous dis
de ce que vous allez voir là c'est à
dire des invités où ça se parle sans
concession et ça y va de sa balance des
très très très gros dos sachez que la
première sera avec les mêmes invités
dans sa voie l'amour voilà regarde trop
la dont thomas pesquet gars y est une
question pour toi
vas-y ça fait dix ans tu fais du sport
c'est quand que ça que voir proposer ces
bouder mais très vite c'est ça ouais il
n'aurait pas choisi sans j'ai tourné
avec bad et on a fait un gros score
ensemble j'ai tourné avec elie dans les
caméras j'ai tourné avec booder donc à
ty ar et j'ai pas tourner encore avec
ahmed
mais puisque vraiment j'en ai pas envie
de reprendre et gab
big lots je voulais te dire un jour j'ai
pris un autre numéro de téléphone et je
me suis fait passer pour toi pour
chébran kelly ouafqa midi j'ai envoyé
des sms pour frère j'ai envoyé des
messages faisant passer pour moi tu es
je suis d un moment d alger ont brûlé
parce qu'elle répondait pas jeudi pour
qui tu te prends djette de merde tu sais
qui je suis
le flou mes copines et je leur ai dit
pareil elle rappelle elle me dit c'est
ton pâté lycée bout d'chou capote j
adore dit mais ça on va y venir en bas
de chez moi ils me demandent mon adresse
il est exceptionnel et ça c'est que je
les fais dernièrement au sujet un
nouveau portable et vous redonne la
technique vous envoyer un message à un
copain ou une copine with voilà mon
nouveau numéro par exemple si vous
voulez vous faire passer pour big lots
et deux semaines après vous commencez à
lui envoyer des messages et après ça
monte en puissance
voilà je pense que je vais passer un bel
été et généralement la copine c'est
kelly je me suis fait passer pour tous
mes potes
voilà voilà mais benhaim va papa va
passer de bonnes vacances aussi
méfiez-vous mais il nous apparaît sur
vous les cherry à moi j'avais un truc
que je voulais revoir
c'étaient les brésiliennes devant
l'elysée avec ça c'était l'avènement de
sacha l'on regarde premier du nom
[Applaudissements]
oui mais voilà
[Rires]
je regardais vue série
[Applaudissements]
magnifique zajal base qui sera bernard à
la rentrée